the factory is up in flames on the
outskirts of bangkok where thousands of
liters of leaked chemicals are posing
a major risk the plastics manufacturer
building
near the thai capitals airport exploded
early on monday
homes within a five kilometer radius
have been evacuated as firefighters
struggle to bring a fire under control
air quality in the area is described as
toxic
we're trying to look for the injured but
the flames are quite high so it takes
quite an effort to look for people
rescuers are also spreading out because
we've got calls for people who have
injuries from the explosion from an
extended area one or two streets away
from here
there are reports of falling debris and
injuries from debris impacts on people's
heads
tony chang joins us now live from
bangkok via skype
tony uh so firefighters have been
evacuating the area
talk us through what's happening now
people we understand from reports on
social media in the in the last
half an hour or so that helicopters have
been spotted going from the
international airports one of them
uh collecting water but they're then
dropping on the site of this fire that
still
appears to be raging a large cloud of
black smoke
which as you mentioned has been
described as toxic by people nearby
uh is still burning up it's now visible
from other cities on the gulf of
thailand
earlier the uh authorities had said they
hadn't got the fire under control and
there was real concern
that it was approaching a huge drum of
20
000 gallon liters of of chemical there's
a fear
that could catch fire and add more
another explosion to what appears to be
an already pretty uncontrollable
situation
video footage from taken earlier in the
day
showed a sight that had been absolutely
devastated by this
explosion it happened just after three
o'clock in the morning and cctv footage
from local homes
shows windows being smashed by that
initial blast we understand
70 homes in the area have been damaged
more than a thousand people have been
evacuated from a five kilometer radius
and at this stage it looks like it's
still not under control
and tony it was a it was a plastics
manufacturing
uh building wasn't it where this began
do we know any more about what might
have caused the initial explosion there
at this stage we don't it was producing
foam for
for packaging but there's a lot of
industry in that area and we've seen
reports in the past couple of years of
people using
unlicensed or unregulated chemicals
again at this stage
very hard to know exactly what's going
on but
uh initial estimates are saying that
it's caused 21 million dollars worth of
damage
already to the ming d manufacturing
plant where it was
and i think there's growing concern that
as it burns out of control
it is it's going to be an obstruction to
the international airport so one of them
which is right next door at certain
points as well it's only three
kilometers away
and that black plume of smoke is uh
getting closer and closer to the airport
the authorities say that air travel has
not yet been disrupted
i think if there continues to be this
large amount of toxic smoke
and the threat of further explosions
that may soon be revised
all right for now uh thank you for that
update tony cheng in bangkok